I really do feel like if Trump gets
reelected you're gonna have all your
dreams come true now and I do mean it
what I should clarify with like okay not
literally 100 of everything all the
political dreams but I think Trump's
going to be like pardoned I think he's
going to Pardon Assange I think he's
going to Pardon Snowden I think he'd
pardon Ross Albrecht I think he's going
to end a bunch of Wars he's going to be
like this is it he went easy on his
first turn because he want to get
reelected and do a this is what they
always do they try to do a little bit
for four years and then a lot in their
last term if Trump gets reelected he's
going to be like I'm pressing the reset
button yeah well it would be you know
there would be no restraints on him this
time around he kind of knows how to
maneuver the system now I mean obviously
he had no government experience going in
but it's now going to be sort of
scorched Earth hopefully
um but you know it is a tough you know I
guess Hill The Climb as well there was a
four six million vote deficit last cycle
and how are we going to close that and
then you know if there is a voter fraud
angle then there's you know most of the
the key Battleground states are either
run by democrats and their legislatures
now or the governorship so it is an
uphill battle